what's in here what does it do and can I
make it from scratch spoiler alert I
actually can't but the reason is
fascinating ingredients now there are a
lot of different ways to get sense into
the air but if you're actually
interested in what those scents are
chemically you're not gonna have a lot
of luck looking at the ingredients of a
product like this now you could go to
the manufacturers website where you will
find a list of every single perfume
scent and fragrance they use in every
single one of their commercial products
but as this list is 20 pages and over
2,000 items long I don't see it being
much help and this is where your nose
comes in well your nose and also the
front of the label because if a product
is designed to smell anything like
oranges or lemons it probably has a
chemical called limonene or also
limonene in it limonene is a terpene
which is a type of chemical that tends
to smell pretty strongly now by itself
limonene is not really that toxic but
when it reacts with ozone something
happens that an old chemistry professor
of mine used to affectionately call a
hbl or all hell breaks loose in other
words a lot of different stuff is formed
and one of the main products is
formaldehyde
now formaldehyde is not really good for
you to breathe in it's an irritant and
if you're chronically exposed to it
probably a carcinogen
okay before we freak out remember that
all toxicity is dose dependent meaning
that if you Huff concentrated
formaldehyde yeah bad things are gonna
happen to you but if one molecule
wanders into your nose you're gonna be
just fine
also formaldehyde is only formed when
limonene reacts with ozone now
ozone is that oxygen mutant that's in a
thin layer of our atmosphere protecting
us from a lot of the sun's UV rays but
it turns out there's enough ozone down
here at ground level and in your house
to react with limonene and produce
formaldehyde but look if you're just
printing a couple times a week relax
it's not anywhere near enough to hurt
you but there are theoretically ways to
produce unsafe levels of formaldehyde in
your house pal well shockingly you can
actually buy a product that makes a lot
of ozone on purpose these things are
marketed as air purifiers even though
they don't check the description I will
post the link with more information you
can also buy products that are designed
to constantly emit limonene say a gel or
a plugin and let's say you've got both
of these going right next to your ozone
generator 24 hours a day right next to
the bed where you sleep without ever
opening up the windows you could be
generating enough formaldehyde to cause
issues
now that's a very unlikely worst-case
scenario but if any of you out there are
sitting right next to your ozone
generator and have four air fresheners
surrounding you just you know give me a
call we need to talk but back to
limonene the crazy thing is limonene is
not made in some far-off toxic chemical
plant it's made in a literal plant yep
limonene is the main component of orange
essential oil and it's present in a
bunch of other citrus fruits too so that
all natural air freshener recipe you
found on Instructables or god help us
all pinterest the one that tells you to
add a boatload of orange essential oil
that has literally the same chemical in
it as the gel or plugin you buy at the
drugstore go figure
I actually like Pinterest so just to
make things difficult let's say I wanted
to make an air freshener without using
limonene or any other essential oil you
might have red right here on the
interwebs that the best easiest and most
natural air purifiers are plants because
there's evidence that microbes living in
the plant root systems and actually the
plants themselves can literally eat
formaldehyde and other indoor air
pollutants so there I made an indoor air
freshener except I didn't we we don't
actually know how well potted plants
like these purify or don't indoor air
researchers at Drexel University are
trying to figure this out by building a
giant wall of plants indoors and then
circulating the building air around the
root systems to see if that makes any
difference
until I figure that out we've got a
couple options for homemade air
fresheners now if you usually use an air
freshener to cover up a bad smell then
the best from scratch all-natural
solution is to get rid of whatever is
making the bad smell and open a window
but if you want to add a nice citrusy
scent to your room then you could just
take some orange peel throw it in some
boiling water and that will release our
old friend limonene just like a
commercial air freshener would so if you
guys have any thoughts on limonene air
fresheners ozone or you know Pinterest
recipes let me know in the comments and
if you have an idea for an episode hit
me up on Twitter in the meantime stay
fresh